hey what's up guys we're going to take a
look at heroes of the storm I went to
into closed beta this week and it's a
bit different from the Alpha that we
checked out earlier last year and let's
dive into it so I can show you kind of
what's different first and foremost you
see through all he's a he's a new hero
that they added I think that was at the
end of the year but um you can see the
UI is totally different from before if
you guys are curious you have daily
quests to get gold so it's not just like
a pay to win or anything like that this
is a free-to-play game or it's going to
be rather and so we can go here and play
you can choose a different hero it's
kind of like Lee league of legends
there's a rotation of heroes that you
get weekly that they cycle in and out
and so right now you have 5 as you level
up higher you'll have more character
slot rotations but these are pretty
basic characters so far I played mainly
valla which is the demon hunter from
diablo 3 obviously and yeah so weakly
they'll change you can also buy heroes
with gold or with money here are some of
those characters and also by skins you
want to do cosmetic stuff which is
pretty cool there's some mounts and also
some bundles the starter bundle is
actually pretty good it's 499 you get
three heroes and war steed but anyways
um go ahead and get a match cute i'm
gonna play as bala nice touch some other
cool things to note is they added a
watch like watch our own replays and a
thing which is cool there's also other
modes that you can select from so right
now I'm in quick match mode but you can
also play like cooperative against the
AI you could also play ranked matches
and they even have custom games now
which allow you
to do like a draft mode which is
something again very similar to like a
dota or League of Legends the difference
with heroes of the storm is these games
are faster and they're on different maps
this is one of the five that are
currently out is called hunted minds
each map has kind of its own scenario
that you have to go through they're
similar but like in this case you go
underneath into the mines you collect
skulls and then you also kill a golem
that's down there and the more skulls
you collect which you'll see in a second
the stronger that golem is this is a
trailer really quick of the map eternal
and the terrors within shell awaken slay
the undead rest their curse skulls in
turn
summon forth hey destroy
I'm going to skip now you guys get the
point I'm already behind so one of the
cool things is earlier on in the game
you're not going to have as many skills
as you see I have they kind of limit you
a little bit in the beginning just to
kind of get your feet wet so that you
can kind of understand better how to
play the game but as you level you're
going to get more skills that you're
going to get to use and it looks like
there's already a lot of action bottom
try to go help them out you might be
able to get the Zeebo here maybe not
oh the pathing is a little oh nice we
got a double the pathing is a little bit
cumbersome right now that you know again
it is a beta sometimes where you click
is it it has collision which is kind of
weird well yeah we did good there we got
we trade it I think we got two kills for
free you can see at the top the levels
it's a group system of leveling so it's
not individual leveling like a dota or
League it's a team kind of thing the one
big thing about here is the storm is it
really is a very team based game it's
very objective based and you really want
to you know fight as a team as you saw
just now and I'm getting it tacked here
but yeah you want to definitely fight as
a team go as a team it's kind of hard to
solo people unless you have your
ultimate skill so yeah always make sure
to be with your team if possible also
another cool thing is you know you do
have the ability to kind of spam your
skills a bit it's pretty forgiving in
terms of using mana it's not like dota
again where you have to kind of manage
it and these games are relatively quick
about 15 to 20 minutes there's also good
I find that like I don't feel as angry
if I lose a game or anything like that I
feel that you know if I lose I just
quickly hop back into another game I par
gonna die here maybe we'll see yeah
that's bad on my part couldn't really go
out though gazal I did a good job kind
of forcing my hand to fight there so
right now they're fighting for the
skulls that are beneath that you saw
earlier hopefully looks like we are
winning down below which is good
you'll get to pick skills progressively
through these each level and once you
get to level 10 you'll get your ultimate
ability or where you usually have two
choices at least and then at 20 you'll
get to you know make that even more
potent so again yeah this is very heavy
Lee this is barely very heavily based on
team play you want to make sure that you
try to do the objectives because the
objectives will help you win the actual
match so this golden will have a have a
big deal in the fights coming ahead
we're actually losing right now 42 to 28
so their golem is going to be stronger
than ours and I think we're not going to
win this fight
you see the habla de is coming back
swift and silent so now they have a huge
advantage they have 70 p 2 i think it
was 72 skulls to are 28 so we're going
to have to fend off a really strong
golem which is probably going to wreck
our base a bit
so you can use the brushes to get out of
trouble he teleported away which is
really smart on his part choose we
really should be stopping there going
guess we're going to trade here I don't
know so you can see their goal looms a
lot stronger than ours we need to stop
this
yeah both fighting
I know why you did that
oh my god as bad
but yeah I mean the other thing about
heroes of the storm that's interesting
too is even though they have the
advantage with this golem it would seem
like in most of the other mobiles that
you would be just so behind that you
wouldn't be able to come back from this
but heroes of the storm there's a lot of
comeback scenarios sometimes you know
you win a game that you don't think that
you're going to win and then sometimes
you lose a game that you didn't expect
to lose
kill these guys
in the test me there's also a jungle
which is pretty typical of a MOBA
there's no warding in this game but
there are a watchtower so you want to
try to control the watchtowers so that
you have you know of course more vision
than that I guess you could argue that
that's a like Starcraft kind of really
we didn't get them inspired I don't
think we're gonna get on the less Diablo
is able to push him back which he did
the lines are open so we should probably
go down now that we have super or our
alternates as well it's going to really
help us all right as I dreaming what the
mines were open unless have been because
they weren't going
oh no oh got out of it
oh I'd i decreed oh he actually got him
the innova i guess i didn't need to go
dive like that but the other interesting
to thing about heroes of storm as well
is that if you pick a character it's not
necessarily locked if you're on the
other team you can still pick that
character unless its draft mode of
course but you know you should be able
to play your favorite hero I think I've
even seen it where you know multi
multiple of the same hero it's very rare
generally you want to try to have a
balanced team so you know there are like
assassin like heroes there are you know
support heroes and tanky heroes so you
know just play the character the hero
that you like to play the most and the
style that fits you most
correct on spa before all right that was
good he's probably running to help is my
guess also another different thing to
you is you have a mount you know you
want to try to use that as much as
possible kind of like wow you know you
don't want to run you want to get on
your mouth don't know if we should chase
here
left
Ice Cube continues not even Jess I don't
know if we can to mend this but would
pry us you want to be careful of the
hero are the golem abilities this is not
good
sweet
okay that was good you also have a
hearthstone that you can use to go back
to your base also good
we'll help Diablo kill their goal
The Golem Sam provide both columns
hmm
if you can even if you're like a tank
there you want to get out of the stuff
the golden cast because it does a lot of
damage to you and will stop you from
doing damage of course you see a
duplicate of me there that's actually
add that there's a ultimate one of his
altima skills it allows them to clone
one of the heroes on our team and he
gets everything that I have which is
pretty cool too he's a specialist take
care of here don't know a good fight to
take
I'd be careful here this is a 40 back
afore guys I don't even know if I can
depend this but we'll try
Oh
ok
oh they're in a lot big control right
now they have lot of mercenaries
attacking this reminder of Nova oh man
these are the some of the mercenaries
right here
clever ploy
fortunately right now that have complete
map control we got to try to get some of
these watchtowers back unfortunately
they also invaded our camps Smee oh I
just I should have done that I'm gonna
die here okay so there I was trying to
show you guys a mercenary camp in the
middle here but they they were obviously
doing it which is bad but yeah
it looks like our team's gonna try and
kill the big golem first which is free
good strat because he drops the most
skulls it's also very risky though
because the other teams probably going
to come after us which they are doing
now
I try to get down there help them
noticed implant this is how we're not
gonna go well
no mercy for the wicked so I was
watching those and dad yeah so we're
probably in pretty bad shape
say eighty six to fourteen going not the
best news
this is really bad
who almost got sniped by their bathroom
not really sure what I actually died to
there that's unfortunate so we're
probably a big trouble here there is a
minor chance of coming back but we
definitely need to stop this goal get
our own golem and try to fight back but
the other team's been doing really good
job of controlling you know the jungle
and getting all the mercenary camps and
they've also been winning the objective
war so kind of in bad shape
I don't even know if I should be chasing
at this point and the stop pop yeah so
he there are certain uh heroes that are
really good at cleaning up mercenary
camps gazebo the witch doctor from
diablo feels really good as you can see
he has like four see gene type much
amazed which is pretty much wrecking our
buildings there that's a new tzivos
ultimate he summons a spirit fortunately
are not fearing i did not see that
so we're pretty much down to our fort
there golem is right next to it we don't
win the mine war here in a second or
pretty much going to be in some really
big trouble
lines are going to open in 30 seconds I
think they're also yeah they just killed
another mercenary camp
blah blah that damn
yeah it's like winning the battle but
we're probably gonna still lose the war
because they're actually attacking a
fort or I pretty much our throne I guess
I try to go stop it hopefully they can
win the war and down in the mines
fortunately I didn't see Diablos message
soon enough
we said using a different the core I
also went back looks like they're
clearing up something to most of the
minds but
Jesus
this is not good my I don't even have
all cuz I used it earlier cuz it's me
andaba thurs clone you ninja job
farm boy
I missed
well please well that sucks that is
probably going to be our demise but yes
either taking over Arkansas pretty much
not much we could do at this point even
though I said there's a lot of comeback
potential we got pretty far behind so
this is one of the one of the many maps
here's of the story so fun one I think
having the objectives and it kind of
forces team play which is you know
interesting mechanic and we'll see what
kind of other ideas that kind of spawn
we're try to check out another nap see
y'all get you guys another look
something different
I'm sad yet we're pretty close
alright so we staved off dying although
i'm not really sure how we're going to
come back and win we haven't even broke
into their base yet fortunately
they just got another worse than I can
we should be defending
oh wow what a clutch saved by Nova
can you see these pax's you want to try
to kill the wizard first
we do it we did have we do have four
dead though I don't know if we can turn
that into anything the mines
unfortunately on up right now
crazy the mines are up now sure we three
we might be able to get around make
something out of it I'll think i can get
to now feeding times we're not gonna
chase him clear this wave and then we're
gonna go down the lines
oh yeah here's we're gonna make a run
for the
yeah it was a really strong hero
they're all it seems I've came back
pretty quickly yes I see
give me a stupid at their work
trying to get it from the edge double
kill enemy
killing spree
why is everyone running uses this is not
good
oh I just died to the great role okay
really need nobody killed this this guy
I me she has the most like
I think she's so worried about
protecting
he goes just after our base
is three siege and soak them to which is
pretty bad I think we'll be able to fend
it off but like barely
so our goal was going to be pretty hefty
we're going to definitely have to deal
with theirs in an ideal world we'd have
mercenary camps but I think they're
going to have the advantage because they
have mapped control right now
we there's a couple of zombies left
that's why nothing spawning yet silent
you guys stopped me from a hard thing
my columns rise again I depart we need
to kildares as fast as possible to paint
their setup to kill ours but and stave
off here I'm pretty much just hanging on
for dear life not really sure I were
going to come back I'm gonna have to
keep getting multiple kills and keep
winning the mine or which may be
stop you're strong
thing is we at least have a birther
who's like shielding the poor and
damaged all right survival number one
are they doing on our goal he is
wrecking shop he's good I try to take a
mercenary camp swift and sign it
you should be able to cut these guys in
alpha but not anymore they used to mess
with their rocks if you credit it
properly
and try to get this middle camp too
just destroy the enemy's core any single
back
I honestly think we should steal their
I'm so good
this land is beyond
did steal that
over
maybe Nova can pick a few off everyone
is pretty low listen heroes but I think
the lines are about to open again we
actually even right now it's
three-on-three the path needs this way
Gavin no problems in power yo golem the
path leads this way
Oh looks like we're gonna have to defend
the core
give it a try
big bucks oh
listen Mary calves this is probably the
end yeah GG so that is a rare game I
guess that that shows you got kind of a
long dis game at the B which is 33
minutes fortunately it ended up in a
defeat but it was a pretty good game it
definitely helps of course if you if you
have any friends that you you can play
with because then you guys can
coordinate better but you know of course
if you want to get into closed beta as
well right now you can buy the founder's
pack it's a 39 99 you get three
characters three skins as well as a
golden cyber mech wolf and if not just
you know try to apply for the beta and
hope you get in during open beta but
that's a quick look at a heroes of the
storm and I was pretty good pretty fun I
guess it wasn't that quick because it
was 33 minute game but hope you guys
enjoyed it
you